at the tip of scotland there is a
treasure island where renewable energy
is the new gold
very traditional sort of one room one
room that's it really
adrian bird has lived on chapensay for
15 years he took us in one of the
islands electric vans to the wind
turbine that's owned by the community
and generates up to 5 000 pounds a day
money that funds a bus an out of hours
ferry and affordable housing this is our
turbine so we're doing something
positive for the community but we're
also taking advantage of clean renewable
electricity to do that
there are more than 600 turbines on
orkney capitalizing on the abundant wind
producing far more electricity than the
islands need but the power cable back to
the mainland gets overloaded and the
energy companies can throttle back the
energy they generate they're going to
put the brakes on now so you can see
they've slowed us right down that must
be hugely frustrating because that's
lost money it is it's a huge loss of
money it will take a while for turbine
to get back up and running properly
again this can happen a hundred times a
day
but now chapensay is turning the excess
power into hydrogen energy once wasted
is in effect stored as a gas to use
later
this is the island school and for
decades it's been heated by oil oil that
was burned in three boilers in here and
of course that oil came from a long way
away and result in large amounts of
emissions now
it's got six hydrogen boilers the
hydrogen made up of the wind turbine
it's local energy and the only
by-product is water
adele is the climate change officer for
orkney council she says the islands show
the rest of the uk how to live without
electricity generated by fossil fuels
we've got hundreds of households with
wind turbines we've got hundreds of
households now using electric vehicles
we generate more than 100 of our own
need of electricity from renewables so
there hasn't been you know a lifestyle
change for us
40 minutes off the coast they're
experimenting with a so far untapped
source of energy the tide
the orbital o2 is the most powerful
turbine of its kind with rotors that
spin in the water rushing between the
atlantic and north sea scaled up
turbines like this could supply more
than 10 percent of the uk's electricity
with the same guaranteed output as gas
or coal the tides are very very
predictable we can look into the future
and tell you any time what the tides are
going to be doing so we're able to
to know how much power and when that
power is going to be coming into the uk
grid to keep the lights on in a net zero
world we will need a mix of renewable
sources of energy but orkney shows the
way
and it works thomas moore sky news in
kirkwall